how about anything we do not tensely
touch in public and then an overtly
sexual manner yeah none of that happens
in public in private you bet
I remember there was one time that I
didn't want to make out I just wanted a
little more elaborate kiss on a New
Year's Eve and you just gave me a little
peck and I was like wow how
disappointing in anti-climactic go grab
my butt and that's fine but like
sometimes he'll go inside of my hands
and my grands hub legs I'm like I
[Music]
wouldn't really be too comfortable doing
the intimate dance in public he Samba is
an angle and partner dance that actually
covers an umbrella of different types of
genres of music and dances I would liken
it to like tango I'm as far as it being
like a walking dance but the music is
definitely african-based it's become
really popular to see like he's Samba
videos where it's slow and sensual and
you accentuate the women's movements and
her curves that are hips which we call
The Boondock I'm actually moving with
each other creates kind of an unspoken
connection so that that's gonna be my
focus today let's get ready took your
phone back now what I want you to do is
walk to your partner and I want you to
give them a hug we're used to having
like improv chemistry I guess and this
is more you just really have to feel
that honest chemistry but also at the
same time remember these moves
these steps me pushing - out this is
bending and straightening main - bugs
one two three four okay good now I'm
gonna have you guys rotate so very
rotate partner
and
not bulldozing her all the downside work
has been like Hollywood big and like
expression and this was like you and
your partner are close and smaller steps
and it's like closer
[Music]
having the people here and then
performing a dance that we just learned
and had to try to do it well in front of
everybody that was definitely test the
confident confidence builder together
she might even get a full kiss I felt
like a channeling energy between the
both of us as a unit that I've never
felt before yeah just try to like sync
up with the other person when it comes
to a dance that you don't know and
you're not skilled with
I was able to look you in the eye for
some of it that's true a lot of it we're
making progress something very new being
that physically close I mean people
dance close but I mean that like that
face-to-face eye contact with eye
contact and it's like very dude and I
liked it I feel like I trust him a
little bit more now I mean it's been
three and a half years but there's
always more trust that can be built